the Pygmalion effect is the phenomenon
whereby higher expectations lead to
higher performance it can be best
understood by a circle where our beliefs
about another person's abilities
influence our actions toward the other
person this action has an impact on the
others beliefs about themselves the
beliefs about themselves cause the
others actions toward us which again
reinforce our beliefs about that person
and so on and on and on let's look at an
example and start with your beliefs
imagine you are the coach of a
basketball team and you observe your
team on the first day Chris and Joe are
new members of your team Chris reminds
you have a famous player Joe reminds you
of an annoying boy from your high school
years unconsciously you decide what to
expect of each one of them your beliefs
influence your actions when Chris enters
the court you are happy to see him when
you plays you push him to do better
practice harder stay an extra hour if he
makes a mistake you explained to him how
to improve when Joe comes in you hardly
notice him you're glad to see him score
but you don't give him much feedback and
don't invest extra time in his training
when Joe does a mistake
you are a little annoyed
your actions impact their beliefs about
themselves Chris feels you appreciate
him and he appreciates you in return he
believes in his own success Joe feels
you have little patience and
appreciation for him he does not believe
in his own success their beliefs about
themselves causes their actions toward
you Chris finds more and more joy and
playing and he never misses a training
session during the games he gives a
hundred percent all the time Joe finds
less joy in playing than before and
doesn't give his full effort in the
games he starts to miss the training
sessions sometimes which reinforces your
beliefs about them you see how Chris
enjoys playing how he trains hard and
shows a fast increase in his performance
Joe seems not to be very motivated his
skills don't increase as much and he
starts to show up less you knew it right
away thank God your instincts were right
the Pygmalion effect is also known as
the Rosenthal experiment named after a
research of Robert Rosenthal at Harvard
in a first study he challenged test
subjects to coach rats through a maze
half the group were told their rats were
extremely intelligent and specifically
trained the other half were told that
their rats were dumb in fact the rats
were all the same
during the experiment however the smart
rats performed well better than the dumb
ones
this showed how the expectations of the
coaches influenced even the performance
of rats
Rosenthal then did the Pygmalion in
school study together with Lenore
Jacobson at the beginning of the school
year a group of elementary school
teachers were told that some of their
new pupils had extraordinary talent and
potential this information which was
completely made up was given about
random average students in each class
all students had done the IQ test in
advance by the end of the year the
students that were described as more
talented had significantly increased
their performance in the IQ tests
compared to the rest of the class Robert
Rosenthal concluded when we expect
certain behaviors of others we are
likely to act in ways that make the
expected behavior more likely to occur
what do you think about this theory and
if you believe it is there a way to
prevent ourselves from being shaped by
others in a negative way if you like
this video and the way we explain the
subject subscribe to our Channel we try
to explain complex subjects and simple
language and cartoons to support
students all around the world in their
learning if you want to support us you
can go to WWII and calm sprouts and
donate just $1 from many fans makes a
big difference
you
[Music]
you